dick Spencer gave us our hero back
and I can't thank him enough
gave us our hero back
it's essentially saying that the weird
Direction the book has been going for 10
years is over
he's writing something that feels great
the character
feels like the triumphant return of
someone you lost a long time ago
[Music]
years ago I made a video praising the
initial 10 issues of Nick Spencer's
Amazing Spider-Man run as a new
beginning for the character I felt great
optimism that a lot of the problems the
ASM comic had over the last decade prior
would finally start to fade and the book
could get back on track to where it was
before well you know
I've read every issue of Amazing
Spider-Man up until this run at least
once and throughout my formative years I
felt very strongly that the book's best
time was in the 70s and 80s the stories
were keeping me engaged with Peter's
personal life the plots were always
building to something important and
something new was always happening to
keep the book fresh
I loved my time with that comic back
then and I'd even start skimming past
the fight scenes just to get back to
that juicy personal life drama that
Spider-Man is known for with the
beginning of Nick Spencer's time as the
lead writer on the book I felt we were
getting back to that Golden Age again
and perhaps we'd see some progression
that the character has been sorely
lacking in the 21st century
but as the Run continued into a downward
spiral of baffling decisions and visible
editorial meddling and subsequent runs
after it fell victim to many of the same
problems it became clear to me that
unless something drastically changes
behind the scenes at Marvel Comics The
Amazing Spider-Man book can never truly
be
redeemed
the Spencer run had a solid start by
bringing the at the time messy status
quo for the character back to something
resembling more of where he was in the
90s Peter was roommates with The
Tragically underutilized Rand Robertson
again Peter and MJ were finally dating
again which gave us hope for one more
day finally getting proper
acknowledgment Peter and Felicia are
finally on good terms again as platonic
superhero friends and Peter was having
to deal with the consequences of some of
the events from slots run
I felt at the time that Spencer's
Spider-Man books were making an attempt
to address criticisms of the book from
Dan slot's historic run on the character
and Dan himself actually replied to the
video to offer some of his counterpoints
this was a moment of growth for me
because of a few reasons it made me
realize that a character writing like
this is still incredibly subjective and
both of us could make an argument about
what counts for being in character for
Spider-Man and both of us could be right
from a certain perspective
it taught me to treat my own opinions
about handling of characters as less
matter of fact and there's a lot of
different angles to look at these
subjects from and that there isn't
always a clear correct answer I actually
agreed with a few of Dan's points here
in this thread but the other bigger
thing it taught me is that b the
creators I talk about are real people
they're not far off magical celebrities
that exist on a different plane of
reality like fictional characters
they can and probably will see the
things that we say about them that can
have a personal effect on them I'd
probably be as defensive as Dan slot is
on social media too if I was always
getting the angry accusatory bile and
hatred he was getting from fans that
were all either angry 15 year olds like
I was or angry alright wackos in their
40s that can't accept social commentary
as inherent to most if not all forms of
Storytelling and I realized I don't want
to be in either group I don't want to be
an edgy teenager slinging mud and
treating creatives like they're bad
people for not riding the ship that I
like in my fiction
I also definitely don't want to be the
type of guy that says things are woke if
they have even the slightest hint of
social awareness or characters that
represent the diverse world we live in
fine
seems like I've become a lot softer in
recent years it's because I don't enjoy
being angry and bitter I don't Revel in
relentlessly trashing things like we all
did when we were younger
it's not fun to be pissed off
I try to be fair and I try to look for
the good in things and I'm still honest
when I can't see the good but I don't
have to be completely reactionary and
rageful and for all these lessons I want
to thank Dan for reaching out and
offering an opposite end of what I
thought was a one-sided conversation
I thought I was just
gonna just talk my no one would
ever be able to hear it or respond to it
or care but
he's a person like me
I don't magically love a lot of his
Spider-Man storytelling now after this
but I've made great strides to
understand it and realize he's just a
guy who loves this character like me so
I can't speak for the toxic fandom but I
can speak for myself and I do want to
extend an apology toward Dan for the way
I villainized him when I was a kid for
no reason other than a difference of
opinion about a silly comic book hero
I've grown up and I've learned
and I'm sorry
also Dan never said this quote that was
poor editing on my part
I was trying to use it as a simplified
visual filler to explain my feelings on
the decisions Marvel tends to make with
their popular characters
but if he actually said it I would have
attributed that quote to him which I
didn't so please stop mistaking this for
a real thing that he said because it's
not
I don't know who said it someone must
have because I heard it like a hundred
times and I thought it made sense to use
but I don't know who said this
so with all that being said how did the
rest of the Spencer run go
did it meet my expectations
well I assumed because of the strong
start that it would eventually stop
focusing so much on addressing
criticisms of ASM and start finding its
own voice and identity
I was expecting it to start progressing
the character forward again in new ways
but the unfortunate reality is that
Spencer's Spider-Man books never made it
past his first phase of going back to
old storylines and trying to put a
Band-Aid on their various blemishes or
unpopular choices
I thought Spencer was only disavowing
more recent decisions with the character
but he was just starting there and
working his way back slots run wasn't
the only thing he wanted to go back and
Tinker with it was
well a little bit of everything
ASM in this time period had an unhealthy
obsession with correcting mistakes of
the past rather than bringing anything
new to the table the books frustratingly
slow pacing was always building towards
another storyline attempting to dive
back into a previous book in retcon or
rewrite a previous writer's contribution
okay let's take a look at one of the
bigger examples
a huge portion of the book was devoted
to revisiting Craven the Hunter and
trying to undo his unfortunate
Resurrection in Grim hunt that stole
some of the impact of Craven's last hunt
JM demattis's Craven's last Hunt is one
of the best Spider-Man stories ever told
and The Tragically dark ending of Sergey
cravenov taking his own life after a
long battle with his mental illness and
insecurities about losing to Spider-Man
drove him over the edge but decades
later Joe Kelley's Grim Hunt storyline
has Craven's surviving family members
uniting and using a dark magical ritual
to resurrect him something even Craven
himself thought was unnecessary Craven
was now Immortal unless Spider-Man
himself killed him which we know would
never happen
now Craven's last hunt feels like Friday
the 13th the Final Chapter it's just a
silly title because we know it became
historically Incorrect and that ending
loses some of its power when we know
that
he'll be back it's probably one of the
most ill-advised character resurrections
in the history of comics which will
become a theme in this video Spencer's
run tried to have its cake and eat it
too I think Spencer is fully aware of
all the issues that the status quo
creates for telling good stories in
ongoing Cape comics
nothing is permanent another writer will
always want to use this or that
character again later on down the line
nothing can be definitively finite but
he made an attempt to work around this
by having Craven create a near identical
clone of himself that's just several
years younger and still in his prime
the story sees Craven attempting one
last time to emotionally break
Spider-Man so that he can finally break
the curse
but Spider-Man's faith and optimism wins
out in the end
so Craven breaks the curse by becoming
Spider-Man in essence and taking his own
life once again it's all very
flowery and kind of dumb he's been
re-killed to bring us back to last hunt
but Spencer future proofs the story by
leaving behind Craven's more powerful
clone to take up the mantle and
essentially be the new permanent Craven
for all other Riders to use in the
future the story has a lasting effect
but will also allow the cycle of
repetition to remain unbroken the
problem with all of this is that it's
ultimately sort of pointless in fixing
what was broken the damage has been done
resurrecting Craven at all still harms
last hunt retroactively and laying him
back to rest again can't undo that
damage the Craven clone running around
is still going to be a blemish on that
original story by not leaving well
enough alone
we devoted dozens of issues to building
up this great Hunt storyline for it to
ultimately end right where it started
there's still an alive and well craving
the hunter running around and Grim hunt
still exists as part of the story the
effort is appreciated but it's just
unfortunately something that can't ever
be fixed
making the effort
less remember when Spider-Man found the
guy who framed his parents for being Red
Skull spies and allowed him to get blown
up no he didn't that guy's fine remember
when Ned Leeds was framed for being the
Hobgoblin and died no he didn't he's
actually fine Gog is just a
misunderstood little guy the tablet of
life and death works completely
differently actually chameleon's origin
story is completely different now the
isotopic genome accelerator Works
differently actually Norman Osborne made
a deal with Mephisto and Mephisto Owens
Harry's Soul retcons are a natural part
of comic books and long-form serialized
storytelling in general and sometimes
retcons can be good
but this is just too much all at once
it's like there's not a single new idea
on display here just riffing on older
stuff in the worst possible way to
improve it somehow and this obsession
with fixing the unfixable would soon
characterize the entire rest of the
Spencer's run leading it to being
arguably the worst run in the
character's history readers have asked
me to fix older stories they don't like
those aren't the stories I'm interested
in telling stories about stories are
Never As Good As just telling stories we
don't need serialized fiction to mend
and paper over older stories we need
them to entertain you said it brother
wait you said that can we talk about
Kindred I'm dying to not talk about
Kindred I'd rather jump in a wood
chipper than talk about Kindred but
let's talk about Kindred for those who
haven't read it I'm going to get the
basics out of the way for the relevant
backstory Harry Osborne went nuts and
became the Green Goblin way back in the
80s and 90s with the intent of avenging
his father's death
we know this one it's a classic arguably
one of the best Spider-Man stories of
all time but Harry's heart gives out
from the batch of goblin formula that
gives him his powers Flash Forward and
habitual loser Mysterio fails to pull
one over on Daredevil of all people and
exits the servers rather than get taken
to jail again then a few years later
Mysterio returns as like a weird demonic
version of himself and then they quickly
forget that happened and he's just
normal Mysterio again
also Peter Parker meets these two twins
that think that he's their dad and it
turns out that they're actually Norman
Osborne's kids who aged way too fast
because Goblin formula or something and
Gwen Stacy apparently cheated on Peter
Parker with Norman Osborne which is
yuck
Peter Goofs up big time and trusts Tony
Stark big mistake and that results in
his identity going public and all of his
enemies going after him Aunt May gets
caught in the crossfire and Peter makes
a deal with a demon Mephisto to sell his
marriage in order to save Aunt May's
life
this results in some bizarre time travel
stuff where history was permanently
changed and the wedding never happened
and anytime he said the word wife you
just need to auto correct that in your
head to girlfriend Mister that's the
brakes
naturally the one more day storyline is
universally reviled because all of that
is a stupid way to undo a marriage
instead of just having the characters
get a divorce like goddamn adults it
regressed Peter's character and just
made him look really bad to do something
that selfish to get the 347 year old
Aunt May like three more years maximum
instead of just accepting reality
part of growing up is that your family
members get old and die
but this guy is not allowed to grow up
so Aunt May will be around forever
he can't be married because that makes
him look too old to be the young
superhero he can't be a father because
that makes him too old to be the young
superhero after all of that happens
Harry Osborne comes back because
everyone with the goblin serum gets an
extra free guy alright so the stage is
set Kindred a mysterious stranger from
Hell shows up covered in giant
centipedes for no reason and he's got
beef with Peter Parker over some
terrible sin he committed that ruined
everybody's lives Mysterio met this guy
while they were both dead and says
Kindred was some damned soul that Rose
to the ranks of Hell to become a really
powerful demon they're back on earth now
and everything Mysterio has done over
the last few years was part of some
master plan that Kindred has had for
ages meanwhile Peter and MJ are having a
hard time scheduling time to be together
and Peter reveals to us the reader that
he has plans to propose to MJ
in the other book friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man written by Tom Taylor around
this time Aunt May is diagnosed with
cancer see a pattern forming all these
pieces fit together it's making sense
but then the problems arise Peter and
Jay get back together at the beginning
of this run just to basically never be
in the same room together
so much so that MJ got her own book
about the stuff she was doing in La
Peter's life outside of Spider-Man is
becoming such a non-entity in this run
that I don't know where he works or what
his social life is like or how his
school stuff is going and weirdly
sometimes even he is barely in this book
because it's so focused on the villains
and everyone's giant evil plans for him
a lot of time devoted to
making Boomerang like a cool character
that's like redeemable
and it's just all terrible I'm sorry I
hate it like I really could not get into
any of that Peter Parker stops being a
character in this run and just starts
being like there he's so reactionary he
just waits for something to happen and
then reacts but his character is so flat
now Kindred pops by to drop vague hints
about his motivation every few issues
across dozens and dozens of issues and
reading this in real time was massively
frustrating because the answer is
becoming more and more obvious but we're
still stalling for time how many
speeches do we have to read through
before you finally say something
actually relevant
Kindred talks about Peter with
familiarity and calls him Pete because
they were friends once Kindred thinks
Peter is a selfish bastard that hurts
people he loves Kindred has a fear of
Norman Osborne Kindred remembers this
party from a way older issue of the book
that Harry Osborne was at Norman Osborne
recognizes Kindred and is like hey I'm
proud of you redacted so much time
wasted
Kindred finally reveals himself to be
Harry Osborne the real one implying the
guy who came back post one more day is a
clone or an imposter which
ruins so many Harry Osborne character
building Moments by just saying oh well
the Clone did those God the Clone
fathered a child and got back together
with Harry's ex-wife
oh my God
all right I can deal with that
so he kills Peter and shows him a vision
of him waking up again at the end of one
more day like it's the exact same scene
we're back there again
why did the anchor forget to lower the
black values for some of this this
looked really amateurish and shitty this
is not how a professional comic book
should look this is Harry's way of
saying his return back then was just as
wrong as it felt at the time and he
reveals himself as Kindred to Peter then
he proceeds to torture and kill Peter
hundreds and hundreds of times in
different ways bringing him back each
time because he thinks he deserves that
for what he did which by the way he
still hasn't said what that is yet I
haven't even mentioned sin eater in the
magic shotgun that makes you act nice
yet
but I can't figure out where to even
bring that up this is such a
already and I haven't even gotten to the
bad part
that's part of the Revenge plan I guess
bring back
sin eater and make him use a magic
shotgun to make people nice again
so part of the evil plan is to make
Norman have a conscience with a magic
wand so he feels bad whenever you go hey
here's all those bad things you did
Doctor Strange is a guest character in
the book and summons Mephisto to
interrogate him about why Spider-Man's
life is getting with so badly
right now by people from hell and then
the book shuts down and things start
getting weird this scene stays in some
odd form of stasis for 25 more issues
like neither character is allowed to
leave the room or say anything that
advances the story Peter loses track of
Harry and then has this big therapeutic
monologue where it seems like Nick
Spencer is talking directly to the
reader about how stuck he feels Peter is
spinning his wheels nothing's getting
done nothing makes sense anymore he's
feeling lost and hopeless
a lot of the resurrections are starting
to get ridiculous
I feel like this is a turning point the
behind the scenes story for this book
has been so vague and unclear we have no
idea what happened while writing this
thing
but I think Spencer was trying to clue
Us in in this issue again everything I
say about Nick Spencer or what was going
on or or any of the intent behind all of
this is purely speculation on my part
there is no evidence to support any of
it it's just what I can interpret from
the material
God please save me please help me escape
this please just set me on fire before I
have to explain Kindred anymore
okay I guess he wants to hear this one
too Kindred is actually not Harry but he
is
Kindred is not one guy but two for kind
of three somehow they're Gabriel and
Sarah Stacy
Gwen's kids with Norman that age like
five times faster than they were
supposed to because of goblin formula
reasons at some point they died off
panel and Mephisto made them his
Champions to try to break Peter's spirit
also they're not Gwen's kids because
Mysterio implanted fake memories in
Mary Jane
and Norman Osborne via hypnosis at the
behest of an AI with evil Harry's
memories even though that used to just
be a pre-recorded message but now it's
alive and evil AI Harry wanted to pull a
prank on Everybody by tricking everyone
into thinking Norman had kids with Gwen
even though telling everyone about the
prank at this point just ruins it
because it's a giant sigh of relief to
find out it was fake and Gabe and Sarah
are just more clones when did Mysterio
meet Kindred in Hell Gabe and Sarah died
years after Mysterio was already brought
back from the dead by kindred
so it can't be them
why is Harry a clone too when and why
did that even happen the story doesn't
even say
why does kindred remember the from
before Gabe and Sarah were born what
about the note in Gwen's handwriting
confirming that they were born was that
a forgery
did Evil AI Harry scan her handwriting
and then print a secret message that
looks exactly the same
why did they disguise themselves as
Harry for so long why do they talk to
Pete as if though they're old friends
they don't even know him
none of this makes sense
my friend Dan gavazden is practically a
Spider-Man historian by this point and
he created the thread on Twitter trying
to make sense of the retcons at play
here
you can read it if you want but all it's
going to do is drive you insane because
there's no real answers to any of this
okay
so
we're doing this again we're doing this
again this is twice now this is twice
whose skeletons are these clone Harry
demon Harry and AI computer Harry
and skeleton Harry are four separate
characters doing completely different
things simultaneously one of them being
dead and one of them gets turned into
Gabe and Sarah at the last minute
and then Mephisto is like Mayday Parker
would beat me up if she's Canon and I
can see the future so that's why I did
one more day so you're probably
wondering with how weird and wobbly all
this got does kindred actually tell us
what Peter's big sin was the thing that
he or they were so mad at him for the
thing that makes Kindred think Peter
deserves to die a thousand deaths
nope
he won't say it
he can't say it
what was the point of all this spending
three straight years being led in
circles just to undo sins past I don't
buy it we were all happy ignoring since
past the book stopped acknowledging it
fans only brought it up and a joking
wasn't that weird way none of us took
that seriously it was a joke and it was
all gone and forgotten
now all that unpleasantness was brought
back just to negate it with the worst
retcon in the history of comics when the
fix is worse than what was broken in the
first place was it worth it and what did
we actually gain from all that Gwen
Stacy's memory is preserved once again
even though that character has been dead
for half a century again there is no
clear answer on what happened behind the
scenes and I can merely speculate but I
think Nick Spencer's Mission plan was to
undo one more day and then that got
vetoed by the people he works for
somewhere along the lines maybe early
maybe later than you'd think
and you can literally watch the scramble
to catch up in those last 20 issues to
try to at least undo sins past as a
compromise so all the build up could end
up fixing
something anything and the end result is
a story so bloated sluggishly told full
of pure nonsense and confusing poorly
executed ideas that I just can't do it
anymore I'm tired of being strung along
for the big reveal to be pulled out of
the rider's hands and turned into more
garbage I can't comment on what Spencer
planned originally but I can guarantee
you it would have probably been better
than this I was happy with how this run
started but it ended up devolving into
such a disaster that I can't keep
investing my time and money into this
series that confidently boasts
storytelling on this level this is
complete greatly ridiculous
I've heard people defend the Nick
Spencer run by saying nobody appreciates
the janitor but Nick Spencer had to do
all this and I completely disagree these
Solutions are creating more problems
that someone else will have to come
along and fix this is the continuity
equivalent of that gag where someone
plugs a leak in a boat and then another
one Springs somewhere else and then they
plug that one and it just keeps going
the ship has sunk guys my God I just hit
my wall with Spider-Man as of this run I
think 70 of my life so far has been post
One More Day stories and there's always
more teasing about undoing it there's
always hints that Mephisto was right
around the corner he's constantly
showing up in other books messing with
other Spider-Man there's always more
dangling MJ in front of the readers to
get us interested again like keys in
front of a baby
everything about this comic that sparked
Joy or excitement in me is gone the
Peter Parker home life drama has been
replaced with constant clones and
implanted memories and time or
multi-dimensional travel it feels like
he's Spider-Man more often than he's not
which at this point feels like a crutch
that these stories have put all their
weight on Peter and MJ being together is
just a button that they press to keep
the fandom interested when they're
getting bored and they have to press it
more and more frequently lately
there's basically never any actual new
villains or storylines just more weird
sludge made up of retconning older stuff
or assassinating characters that
editorial has a vendetta against for no
reason
I'm tired of being disappointed over and
over thinking hey this will be the run
that makes me like the book again and
then having it turn into a flaming
record I haven't really loved a
Spider-Man story since
I want to say new ways to die
then Big Time came around and I know
that's a fan favorite but I just
couldn't get into it
everything since then has been a slow
descent into apathy for me now I just
don't care none of it matters Peter
Parker could die I know he'll just get
brought back MJ could get killed off
because there's a clear bias against her
behind the scenes from the old heads
that grew up reading Gwen's stories
I don't care anymore well one more day
finally be undone probably not but if it
does I don't give a anymore I'm
over the mystery box storytelling at
constant spider-verse team up events
200 years from now you and I will be
long dead but Peter Parker's stories
will still be coming out with him in
college for the billionth time chasing
some girl he's going to break up with
eventually the story has no permanence
and no Stakes it's just repetitive
grueling Direct that's made to keep the
book going indefinitely because the book
makes too much money to ever be canceled
no matter how bad it gets there are
certainly worse stories coming from the
big two but I think Amazing Spider-Man
Takes the Cake by being so maddeningly
mid to low quality for such long
stretches at a time it doesn't need to
be good it doesn't need to be
interesting it just needs to keep
existing as an additional Revenue stream
it's The Simpsons of comic books again I
owe a huge apology to Dan slot because
his run had a lot of the problems listed
but at least something new was always
happening Peter gets a new job or a new
suit or fights a new villain or gets his
brain swapped with Doc Ock or gets a
forgettable sidekick or everyone in New
York gets spider powers or he becomes a
billionaire
I mean the status quo always snapped
back on itself eventually but at least
we were deviating a little bit
I didn't always like what was going on
but he was coming up with things for the
characters to actually do I was at least
interested to see what was happening
next it wasn't 74 straight issues of
backtracking other stories or having the
characters twiddling their thumbs
waiting for something to happen
I was wrong about so much
Nick Spencer's Spider-Man run didn't
bring Spider-Man back
it just made me realize why I'm so tired
of Cape comics in general by pushing so
hard for something big and important
just so the superiors could probably
trash all of it
why are we stuck like this why does the
editorial staff at Marvel demand that
the book continue on like this forever
clashing generational ideologies my
childhood Peter Parker was married
where's my wife you symbiote freak their
childhood Peter Parker was in his early
20s just trying to figure out his way in
the world
but they're the ones in charge not me
they have the authority to make their
vision of him the one that sticks and
the one that stays what I grew up with
was a dream that we all woke up from and
will never see again in this book at
least not until I'm in my 60s and
someone my age is in charge at Marvel
and the current guys have all had their
time
no Goblin serum went up for them but
then eventually someone younger who
loves Emma Stone will come in and demand
for Mary Jane to go back into Oblivion
again whoever the writer is at the time
will get blamed for it just like always
it's taken me two years to write this
video and four or five completely
different drafts
some very angry and from a place of hurt
some versions even more bitter and
cynical than I'm probably coming across
now
this time I just want to go for
sincerity when I tell you this is a very
personal difficult thing for me
but in a way I feel like this helped me
grow up a little
in like a harsh way
like finding out the truth about Santa
Claus or paying taxes for the first time
and realizing that's the rest of your
life I finally realized that the things
that have been eating away at my
enjoyment of this series affect damn
near every popular comic character out
there and it's not something that will
go away lizard syndrome is the default
now
stories without endings just start to
get stale after so many years of playing
it safe or veering away from so many
potential points of growth
I can keep invested in series like Ninja
Turtles or Transformers or something
because you know those keep restarting
and doing new things it's old stories
told with a new filter through a new
lens or with a new direction or
sometimes just completely new stories
that have nothing to do with what they
did before Spider-Man doesn't get those
reboots it is just
doing what it's always been doing
but like not really interesting anymore
this isn't Dan's fault or Nick Spencer's
or even Zeb Wells they're merely a
single component a cog or an egg yolk
perhaps in a giant Rube Goldberg machine
that was designed to kick me in the
balls you're not gonna kick me in an ad
again are you no I'm not Diva those days
are over okay that's the release
that is the best news I've heard all day
what's that thing they didn't build this
machine other men did decades ago I
suspect even the writers at Marvel are
aware of how this works when someone
asked chip zadarski if he'd ever Helm
ASM after writing some of the best
Spidey stories in the last decade for
sister books he basically said why would
I ever want to do that and you know I've
said it before that I don't really have
an interest to write that because it's
kind of the weird expectations and kind
of everything that kind of surrounds it
and people think that's weird because I
go off and do Batman but like but I
understand the audience of Batman better
than I do the audience of Spider-Man
after what happened to Dan Nick and now
Zeb it seems clear that writing that
book is a huge honor right up until you
become the internet's Collective
punching bag for all the things you
can't do
all the things they want but you can't
give them ships got the right idea it's
like when Lex Luthor said do you know
how much power I'd have to give up to be
president him and everyone else are
better off writing the side books that
get canceled every year or two they have
at least some leg room to tell decent
stories in there the name keeps changing
but the story stays the same whoever
writes Amazing Spider-Man is the new
Public Enemy Number One For The Phantom
until the next guy comes along and it's
not fair to keep picking on them for
telling garbled stories while their
hands are tied and every idea they have
resembling growth or change is getting
tossed out by their boss they're the
figurehead that gets all the Flack but
at this point I think they're really
only contributing dialogue
which I mean there's flaws there
too sometimes a good idea or an
interesting story accidentally leaks out
of the machine's structure and we see a
glimpse at something comforting like old
times
but that will never be the default again
while the current players are in charge
at the highest level at Marvel
Spider-Man is Marvel's Flagship
character this could go all the way
beyond the editors of his books and
straight to the tip top of the company
for all we know
I'm not even gonna say editorial could
be the problem this could be some
executive like an Ike Pearl mutter type
that keeps demanding that no he has to
be the young and relatable hero I don't
know who to blame
and at this point I'm tired of trying to
figure it out
but I know someone is causing this and
while nothing ever changes anymore I
just can't get invested
all through the books I read in high
school the book was changing and growing
Peter's character was growing up
alongside me I knew his struggles
because they were happening to me at the
same time it's part of what makes so
many of us initially love the character
we get what he's going through but now I
feel alienated from that entire
relatability aspect of the character
sure I love many characters that I don't
find relatable at all but it's sad that
Peter Parker and I have drifted apart in
that way
that element is completely gone for me
I'm married I have a job my wife and I
want to have kids soon I'm going to keep
getting older and facing the challenges
that come with that
while I do that Peter Parker is going to
be doing the same things he was doing 40
years ago
I'm outgrowing him maybe someday I'll
look back and enjoy his stories again
from the perspective of
uh I remember what that was like for me
at that age but right now I'm just not
interested in that grind
the repetition is killing me and the
thought of picking up another issue of
this makes me anxious I can't do it
anymore
I don't even want to Pirate this book I
feel like reading it at all is somehow
still supporting it so I just
I have to just leave this book behind
for now
I've fallen out of love with it and I
don't know when I'll find the passion
for it again my relationship with this
comic much like with the rest of the
fandom has become toxic
the stories for the foreseeable future
will still be full of stuff that bores
me or makes me angry and I'll see
everyone around me blaming the poor guy
that's writing the book at the time and
missing the entire point of why it's a
problem but they always come back for
more
but I can't live like that I don't hate
watch movies I know will suck and I'll
have a miserable time with I don't seek
out disappointment
and that's all there is in here at this
point so I have to say enough is enough
people will say don't like it don't read
it and they couldn't be more right
I haven't read an issue of Amazing
Spider-Man in two years now
and in a way it feels freeing
but it also felt very sad something that
at one point in my life brought me so
much joy
is now something I feel a bitterness and
depression towards
something I really resent maybe one day
we'll be on better terms again
still enjoy the adaptations of his older
stories coming out in animation games
and movies
but the comic itself
I have to do what Peter Parker can't
anymore
move on
so anyway everyone just go read uncanny
Spider-Man because Nightcrawler is
Spider-Man that's a cool idea I like
Nightcrawler hey also I always get mad
at YouTube for not putting my videos in
the subscription box because people will
comment finally Xavier uploads again
after all these years not knowing three
other videos came out within the last
month already so maybe that stupid Bell
icon thing will help you remember I
exist if you want other ways to support
the channel you can always go hit up
that patreon for early videos and
exclusive stuff because it's just a
dollar I'm not kidding it's only one
dollar Isn't that cool if everyone who
watched this video donated one dollar a
month I'd be able to afford a house for
myself so that would be that would be
really cool you can also check out our
merch on T public or just buy some of my
random stuff on eBay I have a pretty
substantial collection of old toys that
are still in the box in perfect
condition so go take a look in case you
find something you like and lastly since
this is a YouTube video and you probably
play fortnite drop my Creator quote
Xavier GM next time you buy a silly
answer cool character skin really helps
me out
see you next time
[Music]
foreign